[Music]
hey everybody and welcome to gamespot's
third and final wrap-up show here at E3
2014 it's been a long show it's been a
difficult show but at the end of the day
I think we learned a lot about video
games I think we learned a lot about
ourselves and I think we've learned a
lot about Martin Gaston who's joining us
for the second time in a row on this w I
had to fight to be here and I will tell
you that everyone else who tried is now
dead that is very true we have a pile of
dead bodies over there that we're not
going to talk about right now someone
has to deal with that though cuz I don't
like cleaning yeah no well I mean we
have people for that Mary Kish our video
producer extraordinaire is joining us on
the wrap-up show for the first time how
you doing Mary hey I killed Peter Brown
to be
here we said we weren't going to talk
about that but here we are talking about
it hugely incriminating oh wow and Danny
OWI look at that head whopping his big
old meaty tongue I think he's getting me
back for all the times that I put stuff
on the screen behind you guys like like
right now actually um Cameron Robinson
over here at the end Cameron you've been
hosting quite a bit I downstairs you
might say I killed myself to be here all
right I didn't do that no nobody killed
anybody if anything we emotionally
killed people they're still alive
they're just they just wish they were
dead yeah they're a husk of their former
self this wrap-up show got dark it got
real dark right away now uh let's try to
summarize E3 how did it go for you guys
this year you've you guys have all been
here before yeah well E3 yeah oh yeah
yeah oh so how does this compared to
previous years well my my huge
experience of last year and this year
it's been different Sean different it's
been it's been much better I think for
me like the games there's been more
games and I like games and that's why
we're here yeah last year was very much
a hardware show it was Microsoft and
Sony announcing the next generation of
console Hardware maybe going to go go a
little bit light on the games but now is
we're a year into that Hardware cycle
and I feel like we're starting to see
more software yeah absolutely and not
just kind of you know more iterations of
franchises got I picked up all the words
this is awful spend too much time with
developers um it's not just that we're
getting like new new IPS new games which
has been really great lots of new tiles
I haven't heard of before in fact and
not just like big ones too like pretty
much every single game I had on the
stage today I hadn't heard of and that's
not just cuz I'm a terrible journalist
it might partly that right so was
because they were really small games
like there were a lot of them were
kickstarted recently you knowy Dy what
is this Dy that's been weird for me
because I've covered I think three
kickstarted games at the show this year
and it's so odd cuz normally you're used
to like being the vessel of uh
information and opinion from developer
toward fans but with these Kickstarter
games the fans have been in it
throughout the entire process that's the
whole reason they signed up to have that
like transparency so it's been weird
like hex shards of Fate I did a demo on
the live show today yesterday I saw
Elite dangerous it's been kind of odd
yeah that was on the stage today as well
aome that was a good humble
brag well I mean I'm pretty talented at
humble bragging Martin you're going to
say something I have no idea how we're
supposed to cover Kickstarter games
right cuz you you sit down you oh hey
we're playing Elite dangerous it's on
the screen and obviously they want to be
on the screen because games is a big
website a lot of people visit gamesport
it's a great website and but at the same
time the people who are most interested
in this the people most lik to watch it
have been reading blogs and stuff I mean
I know I'm talking about my own job here
but what the hell like how do how do you
cover that like and I'm seeing it for
the first time and then suddenly the
article goes up and what do I know like
this is a you know it's weird kickstar
games are weird and they are difficult
to cover and I am glad I have not had to
do any of them it's challenging but it's
fun cuz they're doing like crazy new
things and it kind of challenges us to
cover games that don't normally get made
like super hardcore space sims like
citizen
space citizen I was about to say Citizen
Space cenace which is a very different
game when will there be movies citiz in
space you know I feel like it's
inevitable anyways what we're going to
do now is we're going to run through
some of our uh favorite things that
we've seen at E3 so far starting with
Cameron Robinson there at the end okay
well favorite things I've seen that I
think so far this year were I say so far
it's over that's all I'm getting right
um the wi of three definitely was uh was
one of my favorites they came on stage
but also their demo they showed off was
was pretty awesome it was everything I
was hoping for I guess because I played
a lot of The Witch 2 really enjoyed it
liked how it was it didn't feel like a
western game if you know what I mean
like it felt different initially because
it was a little bit rougher on the edges
and they kind of smoothed out it but
still it still felt quite different and
The Witcher 3 I still think looks like
it's going to have that you know I was
chatting to developers about it and I I
think it's quite similar to when you
watch like a really high budget I don't
know say Swedish film or whatever right
it's still really great and still just
as slick as Hollywood but it just feels
different and I think the Witcher
three's got that and that's really
appealing for me yeah and I also you can
cut dudes in half which he thrs up here
in a minute I I think we're about to see
that I'm curious like how how well the
open world is going to work because I
played The Witcher 2 and it just seemed
like the T world is so visually
incredible and it just like it begged
for you to get out off the beaten path
and go explore it but you couldn't cuz
that's not the way that game was
designed there were Pathways leading
from One mission to the next but with
this one like there's just so much
promise there do you think it's going to
hold up to like the just the level of
possibilities was bit confusing actually
because when I spoke to them at Gamescom
I was like how open is the open world
and he was like well it's not really an
open world it's like segments and
they're all interconnected and I asked
the same question to the guys on stage
and they were like yeah it's it's open
world so I'm kind of kind of confused as
to exactly where it stands it seems are
you sure you didn't ask one of the
janitors in the hallway that first
question ask him everything he's he just
gives me life advice yeah that guy's
great so I'm a little bit confused on
where that stands um they may have got
confused by my question but um it's
definitely at the very least you're
going to have these huge areas which are
all connected and you can freely explore
plus you can jump now so that's quite
great so you can like properly get R
into the bonus can he always jump or can
he just jump when he's up to a ledge and
it says press a to jump you can jump at
any time I think okay whereas before all
you could do his roll so he's come a
long way yeah good for him good good for
him he seems like a really talented guy
that geralt of Rivia uh did you get to
see anything else cam yeah Far Cry 4 was
probably my other
highlight that is that is the one or one
of the several games actually that I
wanted to find time to go and see but I
just never could I didn't get hands on
with it but they did come on the stage
and did like show off a demo and it just
just talking to the guy about how um how
the cor is what I'm so excited about the
fact that you can just like see a
mountain join up with the budy climb
that mountain and then just like wing
suit off it together and then go blow a
whole stuff up like it just it sounds it
just sounds like even more of a
playground than Far Cry 3 was I I mean
I've heard from certain people I think
like Dan Hines came back and described
it as it's more Far Cry 3 but still
that's going to be pretty awesome does
do you get that sense yeah I think so
but um I think it's almost like they've
they're taking it like they really tried
with the story last time they tried to
do something that initially made you go
oh God this guy's such a jerk I hate him
and then that's kind of the point this
time I'm I'm not sure they're so F about
the story I think it's I mean I'm sure
they are but I think the focus is more
just giving like the best possible
playground right that's that's what it
looks like to me anyway but you can ride
elephants into compound and stuff just
just seems like a lot of fun I'm I
wonder how like the mountains are going
to work out because there were there
were Hills in uh Far Cry 3 but you could
always get up them and occasionally you
would run into like a really tall
mountain with a sheer cliff and that
would create this kind of like
impassible barrier and you'd have to
find another way around it do you think
think with this new setting you're going
to get more of those impassible sheer
Cliffs well I don't know I mean like
Skyrim's got a mountain setting and it's
quite actually easy to constrain the
player with that you know um but you you
have a grapple gun so I don't know like
is it do the grapple gun just connect to
specific points or like we haven't
really seen that yet so I'm not entirely
sure but they'll probably constraint it
with that but then you've also got the
jungle stuff like lower down um so yeah
I think there'll be some sort of
impossible maybe impossible River I
don't know and the big question is the
elephant the weaponized elephant the
elephant in the room yes the elephant in
the middle of the room when you when you
weaponize it does it die I don't know
well it like it Rams that car in the
demo and doesn't and explodes and it
doesn't die it doesn't even have any
armor on is it is it a is it like a
mythical Supernatural elephant of you
guys have ever taken down an elephant
you don't know how much I don't think an
elephant can withstand an explosion like
that I mean I could be wrong I might be
wrong but I think only one way to find
out pretty wrong maybe the elephant is a
metaphor for ourselves two elephants I
don't know for a game
bug so those were your kind of two
highlights anything else that uh stood
out to you um I I really enjoyed seeing
Elite dangerous today I think the game
looks crazy and so big I still don't
know how exactly the game play is going
to be like I haven't really got to try
it yet but the scope of it appeals to me
I got to check that game out yesterday
and I had a great time with it I also
don't understand the scope of the game I
never played any game in the series I
think the first one came out like two
weeks before I was born so no excuse I
know I could I could have gone back and
played it at some point but you know I
was too busy uh watching Sesame Street
and pooping in my diaper anyways let's
not talk about that let's talk about
Elite dangerous what what are what
appeals to you about this specifically
just how just how big it is and the fact
that you can kind of do whatever you
like within space SP and the fact that
there's also Oculus support now as well
with DK2 and the the mustion tracking
camera so you can like look around your
spaceship and lean into stuff and you
could just sit down and you could spend
like hours just like cruising around
space being a pirate or whatever and
that freedom is quite exciting and it
looks looks really gorgeous too uh so
you hosted the stage demo right you
didn't get to do the Oculus for yourself
no I haven't I haven't tried this with
oculus so I got to try the Oculus demo
and let me tell you when you're doing
that using one of those crazy scitec
joystick setups where you have like the
joystick over here and the separate
throttle module over here and they both
have like a dozen buttons on them that
is confusing when you can't see any of
those buttons and you're just going by
feel alone um it's uh it's really
intimidating like it was really hard
just like undocking from the space
station and like getting through the the
space lock yeah well they're unly a
hardcore about it like they say they're
making the game for themselves and they
want have they want to have all the
controls they want it to be as realistic
as possible basically the only thing
where They're Taking Liberties is like
okay the one thing which we're going to
like cross our fingers about and say you
know what just ignore that is like fast
and light travel everything else they've
tried to be like faithful with so like
they create gravitational fields inside
uh spaceships because they have these
giant rotating rings and this like
potential you know research says that
might be a way of creating like it's
like half a g of gravity and also like
the space centers have half a g of
gravity because there's also research
that says that would be a healthier
level of gravity live at than W so there
all this like Mass of Science nerdery in
there which I love but I think it could
turn quite a few people off but we'll
see all right cool uh thank you Cameron
Martin we're going to move on to you now
like oh that just flew over your head
sorry that you're not a man of science I
don't many G and gravity I've got but
I'm happy with where we are right now on
this dangerous ass stage that's almost
certainly going to kill one of us I wish
you guys could see it because it is
terrifying but little wooden
blocks that are all sort of higy pigy
put on the ground and then nice
description we got to put our chairs on
top of them we're precariously placed on
top of yeah that makes it looker it is
balance I wish you could see how big the
gaps are it's like a poorly poorly
designed 3D platformer we're in danger
we're in danger if we if one of us dies
tonight it's not cuz Mary killed us at
the same time I do believe the whole
state is beautifully made have an Ali
it's great stage I like it made now
Martin to the point at hand video games
SLV video game Trends SLV video game
news yes so I want to talk about two
things basically I think Nintendo had
the best show the best showing their
conference was great uh and I think Sony
make the games I want to play so walking
around the Sony Booth it's fantastic
there's just you go to the Sony booth at
E3 and everywhere you look it is filled
with greatl looking games a lot of them
smaller downloadable types but the thing
I really want to talk about is Microsoft
because I think they had a really good
show this year uh which was incredible
because I was convinced they were going
to completely ass it up like I was
convinced after last year's showing and
all the terrible terrible decisions
Microsoft has made over the past year I
was convinced we were going to sit down
it be Monday and Microsoft was going to
just really ruin everything but um no I
think they've had a really good show I
agree and I haven't I haven't seen as
many people talk about Microsoft as I
think Microsoft deserves to have I think
Phil Spencer is doing a fantastic job
from what I can tell he always talks
with one hand like down and the other
hand oh floating around I've never
noticed that and I'm going to tell you
that now and every time you see him talk
he will do that that's how he talks that
is one hand rotates around a bit and
that this is me being mean cuz I
probably like a complete fool when I'm
on screen as well but um no I think M
has done a fantastic job uh their
conference had no executive waffle MH
and I think the most telling thing was
that they relegated this cool new like
achievement tracking application which I
don't think many people even know about
even though they announced it at E3 yeah
they relegated that discussion to their
pre-show because I think they're so
afraid of talking about anything now
that's not games in their actual show
they won't even talk about interesting
new features coming to the Xbox one they
are you didn't hear the k word like I
didn't hear the k word at all anywhere
this year that's true and were there
even any connect games I there was um
Fantasia oh yeah there was yeah but like
that's more like oh we got to release
Fantasia now cuz he's crap of
money on it like it's not like oh
everyone have a look at Fantasia Dance
Central I guess but I don't know some
good strategy with that though I mean
they announced the connect before E3
that they were going to have the connect
list Xbox one before E3 specifically so
that it wasn't the thing that was talked
about at E3 exactly right to get that
out of the way like they took that hit a
month ago that's right and so it's
they're an interesting company and I do
believe like I genuinely do believe even
though their machine is currently seen
as like less powerful I do think they
will fix a lot of what went wrong for
them with that disastrous reveal last
year I really do and it might take some
time and the way I see it now is it'll
be a reversal of
roles from between Sony and Microsoft
last generation so remember when the
PlayStation 3 came out and it didn't
even have PlayStation Network like a lot
of people forget the PlayStation 3
launched without PlayStation Network
that's true yeah and they had to patch
that in they had to patch in
online that was crazy right and
Microsoft as well launched their Xbox
One with loads of stupid things they've
had to change but I do think a couple
years down the line they will they would
basically caught up I think we see some
good first party games coming from
them and um yeah I would suggest
everyone go back and have a look at
Microsoft I think they did a pretty
decent job and what's your take on EA I
think EA did a terrible job oh right
little uh little compare and contrast
EA's thing for me is indicative of of a
big problem at E3 this year in that
everything that I want to play is not
coming coming out this year yeah we saw
that with Nintendo as well everything
that I want to play is is 2015 I am
pretty worried about what I'm going to
play this Christmas and I think there'll
be some good games but so much of what
was on show at
E3 was was for down the line like
nothing does it more than this Mass
Effect Effect trailer where we saw this
a lot of EA conference where someone
would come out in a in a video and I
mentioned this on the rap show yesterday
and they would be like oh here piece of
concept we are working on it we promise
like this game is a long time away yeah
like and the fact Mirror's Edge 2o as
well like or whatever they want to call
it Mirror's Edge the fact that that game
was announced last year and they are
still showing off what have they been
doing for the past year but they are
still showing off videos and like
building faith it's like when we know
more mir's Edge last E3 did this E3 but
we know how they built Faith they took
the picture of her basy from the last
game changed it a little bit made her
look and uh and and there is obviously
more work to it than that but like
they're trying to sell us the idea of
creating this character it's like she's
already been made guys like I played a
whole game with her in it I'm pretty
sure about what you know look at her red
shoes Martin look at her red shoes I
know but they're just it's it's tough
like I can appreciate the difficulty of
EA's position that they are making these
games and they are very exciting and
they're probably not making the kind of
progress that they would like but to
come to E3 and just be like yeah here's
here's some pictures of stuff like look
we're doing things for real um the thing
with this that I also find interesting
is talking about the kickstar games is
the
way big Publishers the way they think
about
presenting game development to us is
that changing are we going to start
seeing games being announced at a far
more conceptual stage to how we were in
the past cuz EA would never have done
this 5 years ago EA never would have
gone look here's some people sitting
around a room as we get a professional
video crew into you know film us just
pretending to be normal mhm uh they
would have shown it when it was
basically ready to come out right is
this how it's things are going to happen
now are we going to see games being
announced at this stage more and more
often that is quite interesting to me
but at the same time I really didn't
like it during the EA conference and I
maybe that's just me being an old man
that's used to things being done a
certain way but um I don't know I
thought EA's conference was was very
very underwhelming this year so which is
tough cuz I do think EA is a very good
publisher and I think in the past I mean
it looks like they have some great games
in the works it's just the way they went
about discussing them I want them now
I'm impatient I'm impatient and I want
them now God damn it and but marized was
particularly grating to me because they
showed it off last year and I I would
have expected to have seen more but
maybe that's just me being an entitled
27y old G journalist that sits on this
stage and just says stuff out loud
without really thinking about the
reality of the situation for reality
think saying stuff out loud without
thinking about the reality it's time for
my segment let's talk about some of the
games that I saw we're going to shift it
to a slightly more positive note because
today uh I had an appointment with the
game earlier in the Sony booth and
normally day three of e3 is kind of when
you start to see the drgs of the
appointment schedule you saw the really
cool stuff at day one maybe some of the
surprising stuff on day two and day
three is when you go and you see the
Nintendo 3DS licensed movie tie-ins
about cats and dogs that you just make
you want to kill yourself excellent film
that cat and dog game won your heart
that did that did that is my favorite
preview that I've ever written to Eddie
three um but today I got to see uh
everybody's gone to the Rapture oh
everyone is loving that game everyone is
absolutely loving that game so uh just a
little bit of context for you guys if
you're not familiar this is by a uh tiny
little studio in England called the
Chinese room and they made a couple
years ago they released the deester and
more recently they worked on the second
Amnesia game a Machine For Pigs and dear
eser was a it was a very interesting
artsy uh mood piece kind of a game where
you're kind of you're walking along this
preset Trail through this very
atmospheric very kind of creepy Island
and as you progress along you hear uh
these voices in your head or I don't
know if they're in your head but you're
you're kind of like triggering these
audio cues and it's basically it's like
a creepy it's a very creepy thing yeah
it's almost like you're hearing a man
writing a letter to a long lost love or
something like that you see it on Steam
sales for like a p50 all the goddamn
time so people like pick up Dear Esther
it's it's pretty decent it's a great
game but it was also more of a proof of
concept than anything else because the
the game itself was in terms of gameplay
is very very rigid very limited it was
all story this one it's similar in the
sense that it's very much focused on
story but it is an open world right yeah
so you can you can walk around there are
multiple different sections of this
world and it's what's interesting to me
is that it's a post-apocalyptic game but
it the setting it's a very pristine
idyllic picturesque kind of English
Countryside farm town and you
are you are exploring this kind of like
very recently lived in World kind of
like gone home did you guys play that
yes that's a controversial game that is
a controversal I love G someone's going
to be like oh got yeah but it's kind of
like environmental detective work you
know you're kind of like trying to pick
up the pieces of like the people who are
living in the space and it's similar and
everybody's gone to the Rapture except
it's a very Supernatural kind of thing
so like let's say you're Crossing this
you know this wood or this Stone Bridge
through this kindy tiny little uh
English Countryside town and you see
these kind of like faint Echoes of past
uh people just these Silhouettes having
a conversation about a child's birthday
party or whatever and at other times it
might be something that's a little
harder to hear like you're walking
through a house and you hear Whispers of
a voice within another room okay um
would you say it was Sinister or for
boing no it wasn't it wasn't at all it
didn't have like a doom and gloom
post-apocalyptic feel was like always
about like aesthetic it was about that
immersion that natural immersion that
you get from um it was really simp
simple um audio cues um visual cues that
make you feel like um just making sudden
steps impacts the world which is a
powerful thing to be able to do in a
game right and what I like about this is
that the story is tied so much more to
the makeup of the world it's
1980s England it's a you know small
little town the the the cold war is out
there these people are afraid of like
what's going on in the world and to that
the apocalypse is happening and it just
kind of like it's this theme of these
people who live a fairly insulated life
and they're not really ready for what's
out there and it's just it it it applies
on one level it applies on another level
and it's just really interesting you
feel like these very personal
interactions as you're walking around um
and and it looks just absolutely
gorgeous man that sounds fantastic
when's it out it is out I don't know
probably not this year I'm going to
guess 2015 it is unlike I'm looking
forward to seeing an advanced Gameplay
trailer next E3 next E3 it'll be great
it is going to be a PlayStation 4
exclusive uh the Chinese room is working
with Sony Santa Monica it so it's an
interesting relationship and that game
just I I loved hearing uh the creative
director Dan pinchbeck talk about it
because that is a very smart guy seems
like a wrer and that's Sony have got it
made right Sony been making these
relationships for the past three years
that's what when I was talking about
going around the Sony Booth right you
there are loads of devs there the C3
they are all talking about how much they
just they love what Sony is doing right
now uh one developer who prefer probably
not to be named said to me today that he
is just worried that it will end like
Sony wake up and be like Oh done with
that and just be like No Sa off uh but
he's so a lot of developers are so happy
with what son's doing and you see great
game things like this that everyone I
know who's G to seen everybody's went to
the Rapture just comes back like oh I
have to have it right now um oops my mic
oh
no well that's a great opportunity for
us to cut to a quick commercial break
while I try not to Die My retrieving my
oh no it was the other thing it was the
thing that lets Tai talk to me don't
worry guys we'll be right back Fu
technical diffic Furious and crisis
averted don't worry guys you sced you
were sced hard in that alive actually he
died and this is a clone I learned my
lesson Sean clones do not do not drop
whatever microphone pack that was uh but
is taken care of and now we're going to
move on to talking to Mary Kish do you
guys want to know what I saw in the 30
minutes I was allowed to be on the show
floor yeah you yeah um most of my work
is right here in this war room you can
see my computer back there actually
that's pretty much where I spend my E3
but um I did get to see some sweet uh
Indie booths they've really done it this
year so Sony's kind of known last year
they had a huge Indie Booth where you
could see all sorts of sweet upcoming
indie games and uh Microsoft's kind of
taken it up a notch and they had one too
and I think that's really cool to to be
able to get your hands on games like you
know threes and uh I saw alien traps
aean and um below lift rousers is here
in the Sony booth and it's really cool
to see some of these these uh games that
are incredibly creative and um engaging
and interesting and they like man
they're addictive did you get to play
through uh I I've played it not here I
saw it at the show floor and I was
really excited I how it work I can't
wait in line I don't have time if I can
actually say Xbox go to 3s I would
probably just vegetate on the couch
until I die yeah so well that game is is
cripplingly addictive that's right I
mean what they do is they find ways that
they take um a mechanic or some kind of
idea where you're like well that was
that was such a simple idea but they
think about it for a long time you're
talking about years of development where
they're perfecting these simple ideas to
make them as addictive and and as
interesting as they are so there is a
lot of thought and effort that goes into
them and it's sweet to see them in in E3
uh so I'm looking forward to seeing that
more but uh in my other 30 minutes on
the show floor I played uh evolve ooh
okay this is my second time playing it I
got to play it at uh P East as well um
that was when I played with Goliath uh
and I played as a Trapper this time I
played against Kraken and I was a medic
um now there's you know there's the new
monster and there's even the new classes
and it's amazing how different they made
the classes it's not like the new medic
is just a dude it's not a pallet swap
which he is yeah um they didn't give
them new skins they gave him completely
new abilities I find that amazing the
amount of balance that's gone into this
game that like the old medic was kind of
like the medic U with the heavy you know
who like kind of had this stream that
helped Health people but the medic that
I played is a revor and um has a cloak
cloaking device and stays hidden so my
medic was more about not being in the
action at all um using my silent sniper
rifle from really afar and then cloaking
to revive people secretly um without the
without the Kraken ever noticing me
would what a completely different
gameplay style than the last medic uh
and it still ends up being a balanced
game with these very very very different
character classes I mean it's just it
continues to be such a surprisingly
amazing game it has not disappointed me
I mean I don't want to like bash on any
games but like it's funny like every
time I hear I was so psyched for Destiny
and every time I hear or saw new
gameplay I was like oh and I wasn't as
excited it's building on this excitement
and involve just continues to be more
impressive again and again it's got to
be one of the games of the show
Absolutely yeah did did we give it one
of the things we I don't think you have
authority to say that now maybe oh no
spoilers um now Mary you as you said you
didn't get to spend a lot of time
walking around on the show floor because
you were very busy right over here
that's correct uh I'm afraid your
monitors gone to sleep that's a shame
I've had a lot of fun with that
throughout the show um know there's a
lot of things that happen behind the
camera you know there's a lot of people
that go into making the show as amazing
as it is in addition to Fantastic
incredible Talent you mean like Sean
like Sean oh um you know you're you're
talking about uh a tremendous group of
talented hardworking people um you know
Ryan Mack who's like directing the show
floor Jan air a technical genius who is
frightening how smart he is and um just
a slew of hardworking crew members that
never disappoint and it's it's funny you
know you get difficulties in any show
like this and um there's been so few
hiccups and I I find it I mean it's
overwhelming I this is my second time
there's Jan that's my this is my second
time now doing this and it's shocking
you have people you know that have been
doing this for like 10 years a decade of
technical expertise going behind
Gamespot and I think that's really
amazing that Gamespot even brings that
to the table you don't find that a lot
um these people have been doing it for
years they're the best at what they do
and you never really get to see them
they're the like silent protagonists
this is our hardworking crew um we're
bringing you um the other side the video
component of a lot of the stories that
you guys love so much so in addition to
the live team we you know we're talking
to Kevin Bard and Tom McShay and Peter
Brown about you know the games that they
saw that they loved so much and we're
filming them make sure they talk about
it that's that's a that's exclusive you
can't see that yet and um you know kind
of cutting these pieces together so that
people can see the game for themselves
and make their own opinions based on on
this cool content it's a thrill to be a
part of and we love what we do uh and
it's really cool you know to be able to
tell you guys that we exist uh look at
some more people that you didn't know
lived but are a huge part of Gamespot
without these tiny back area none of
this stuff would be possible we bring in
a giant truck of electronic gear I mean
it's insane this is me working uh um
well that's Rob working um it's really
hard to express just how much effort
goes into the work um we have to
concentrate really hard there's a lot of
thought that goes into it um right now
there's some creative genius going on
and uh I mean I really couldn't I
couldn't go on but there's really
nothing else to say it speaks for itself
yeah yeah there's definitely a lot of
magic behind the scenes yeah I mean
there's nothing I don't want to give
away our our our industry Secrets um
because they're they're very important
but but we do a lot of drugs yeah is
that yeah it's mainly the meth is the
secret uh but yeah I mean we could
definitely go on at length but that
basically long story short a lot of very
talented people who put in some very
hard hours to to give you guys all the
incredible stuff that you see on the
website right now so thank you Mary
everybody else you're welcome and yeah
we have a lot of crew so it's good to
it's good to have you guys see all that
cool stuff there's even cameramen back
there they're on us right now they'll
never get seen they weren't in the
b-roll they're the
silent silent Heroes now as we wrap up
on E3 2014 I want to ask you guy or you
guy you guys and ladies and lady I'm a
lady uh you know what do you guys think
about the show overall uh thumbs up
thumbs down looking forward to next year
definitely thumbs up for me thumbs up
yeah it's been really it's been a great
show I think as I say based on my giant
experience of last year and this year
it's been much better for me I've really
enjoyed it my 30 minutes were fantastic
what a 30 minutes loved everything
playing evolve is amazing I love being a
part of it it was awesome and seeing all
the conferences I mean they're really
kicking it up I love seeing the games
there's so many cool things I'm really
excited to really excited for some stuff
to come out good let's go 2015 is going
to be great the message of this E3 2015
and 2016 are going to be there's there's
a real mood I think on the show now it's
a real optimism now that the consoles
now the PlayStation for the Xbox One
have come out and they've both sold I'd
say yeah record numbers uh that there's
that we're going to see some real
excitement in the game industry over the
next few years there's a lot of
excitement with developers and I think
there's uh a new willingness willingness
perhaps from this whole Kickstarter
thing for developers to actually listen
to what people who are playing games to
have that dialogue to have that Exchange
in a way that in the past was just
something they would say out loud to
them because they thought it sounded
nice absolutely fact I was CH to guys
making a game about building like a a
space station around the earth after the
Earth is destroyed called habitat that
was it and he was I was asking one these
questions he's like well you know I
actually don't know the answer to that
yet because I'm basically just going to
hand over to the community and they can
tell me what to do so there's definitely
a lot of that going I think that's
becoming a genuine thing across across
many many many many many many many
Publishers not just ones that have seen
success on Kickstarter uh I yeah had a
really great time played so many great
games on the Sony Booth 7 games on the
Nintendo booth on the Microsoft Booth
other booths the other third party it's
it's been you know it's a fun time it's
for as many uh struggles as the video
games industry has had over the past
couple years it's still magical shows
like E3 are still vital and it's been a
lot of fun I'd like to say I have said
you said it right currently saying would
just like to say I will say it once and
for all it's been a great show so thank
you very much Martin Mary and cam for
joining me on the stage here we all
survived yes we abolutely did I'm really
s we should end by all falling backwards
at the same time
I'm not going to do that I'm not even
going to pretend to do that and thank
you as well to the rest of the crew that
made E3 happen here on gamespot.com
everybody behind the cameras everybody
at their computers everybody writing
everybody down there on the stage it's
been a lot of fun and thank you there it
is there it is there it is cuz without
you guys none of this would happen thank
you so much than for watching and we'll
see you next year
goodbye
[Music]
n
[Applause]
[Music]
he
[Applause]
[Music]
he
[Applause]
[Music]
a
[Applause]
[Music]
he
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
a